hallo und willkommen zu einer neuen Episode von
Easy German heute sprechen wir über
häufige Fehler, die Deutschlerner machen,
wenn sie Deutsch sprechen, und
ich freue mich sehr, Ihnen heute dieses Video zu präsentieren,
weil wir
sehr lange daran gearbeitet haben  Im Grunde genommen
habe ich das ganze letzte Jahr über heimlich
Notizen gemacht, wann immer ich mit Menschen gesprochen habe
, die Deutsch lernen, und mit diesen Notizen habe
ich eine Liste der
häufigsten Fehler zusammengestellt, die
ich immer wieder höre und die
wir heute vorstellen werden  Ihnen die ersten
10 Fehler und vielleicht einige Tipps und
Lösungen, wie Sie sie vermeiden können, und
ja, dieses Video wird auf Englisch sein,
weil es etwas länger sein wird
als unsere regulären Videos, und wir möchten auch, dass
Sie sich auf die Fehler konzentrieren und nicht
auf die  erläuterung vor
beginn abonnieren sie bitte easy
German und werden sie auch pate wenn sie
online übungen zu den
in diesem video vorgestellten fehlern machen
wollen fangen wir mit der fehlernummer an  Erstens
gibt es zwei mögliche Übersetzungen für
das englische Verb to know auf Deutsch,
nämlich canon und listen, und das ist
auf Deutsch ein bisschen kompliziert, weil
man den Unterschied zwischen
diesen beiden Wörtern erst lernen muss
korrekterweise würde man sagen, Zee
vicinage way his visa man ging also was
ist der eigentliche unterschied zwischen diesen
beiden wörtern der unterschied ist, dass kenan
sich immer auf spezifisches wissen,
etwas spezifisches, eine spezifische person oder
eine spezifische sache bezieht und normalerweise
mit einem substantiv beantwortet wird  oder pronomen jeder
caner anständiger mann
jeder kennedys im film kann man in jedem
kann nicht Dino motor
zum beispiel aber wenn man über
vision spricht spricht man mehr über abstraktes
wissen etwas was man nicht weiß oder
zum beispiel allgemein etwas das man
mit einer relativen klasse beantworten würde  auf
Deutsch zum Beispiel
zu Lesern Vuitton Morgan Viet jeder
verschwindet mit uns, dass unter Viet Oda Vice
zu verschiedenen Visa Mitch Powe  Wenn
ich verschiedene Visa Miss Pro geklaut
habe, haben wir einen kleinen Dialog für Sie vorbereitet, um
zu sehen, ob Sie die unterschiedlichen Ratschläge von
Fosters in diesem neuesten Akt erhalten haben. Sie können sich
vorstellen, dass Mäuse neun den freundlichen, unhöflichen Feliz oft verklagen können, aber
sie sprechen über die
Straße  Rat vermisse das Feld einer
Philosophie, die ich aber nicht investieren kann, dass
jeder Virus gut ist, und ich
begann mit der Entschuldigung, nachdem ein paar Menschen im Leben ein
Gerät über die Dunkelheit getragen hatten, da
Sokrates dachte, dass der Bericht von
Grönland Thibodeau dazu bringen kann,
was Philosophie neun Akademiker ist
Elitismus II Typischer Fehler auf unserer Liste ist das
Verwechseln von Angst und Xia. Beide Wörter sind
in ihrer Übersetzung sehr ähnlich, aber sie
haben geringfügige Unterschiede, also sind hier
drei Fehler, die ich mir notiert habe, die Kelsey
während der leichten deutschen
Sommerschule als hinter Zahnseidespielzeug Sophia und
einem anderen sagte  Mitglied unserer Sommerschule sagte
Herr Van, jeder Engländer sei wie Hoover,
konzentrierte sich darauf, es so gefühlsmäßig von der
Musik zu machen, und ein einfacher deutscher Zuschauer
schrieb weiter  youtube each mark dizzy foger
guns fear also eigentlich ist angst in all diesen
drei fällen das falsche wort und
es hätte das richtige wort gegeben
und hier ist eine einfache möglichkeit, sich daran zu erinnern, dass
angst ein Adjektiv ist und normalerweise
mit Substantiven
als Adverb verbunden ist  und es ist normalerweise
mit Verben verbunden. Wann immer Sie also eine
Handlung auf Deutsch beschreiben, sollten Sie Xia verwenden und
wann immer Sie ein Substantiv oder
eine Person beschreiben, sollten Sie Furcht verwenden, wie
Bascom befürchtet hatte, aber wenn es
mit einer Handlung verbunden ist, sollte es da sein  hatte
bloß Xia the Fallon, wie man ihren
Hintern mit Zahnseide behandelt. Das nächste Thema, über das wir
sprechen, ist das englische Wort to
take und das deutsche Wort naman when a
man ist wahrscheinlich die wörtlichste und
direkteste Übersetzung von to take auf
Englisch  Verwenden Sie dies nicht immer auf
Deutsch, also schauen wir uns die beiden
Beispiele an, die ich im Easy Journey
Summer School House aufgenommen habe - dieses Foto in
Dinah Volune Gentleman. Haben Sie
dieses Foto in Ihrer Wohnung gemacht und wenn
Harbor Island Park ist Kinnaman. Ich
habe einen Sprachkurs belegt, in beiden
Fällen war die Übersetzung von to take und
naman hier nicht korrekt und daran zu
denken, ob Sie to
take auf die körperlichere Weise übersetzen würden oder wenn
Sie einen Satz haben, der es verwendet  auf eine
physischere Weise kannst du zum Beispiel meinen
Rücken zu meinem Natasha-Namen bringen und dann hat
Niemann wahrscheinlich Recht,
aber wenn du einen Ausdruck verwendest
oder wenn to take im englischen
Ausdruck verwendet wird, solltest du es bei der
Übersetzung mit name und überprüfen  auf deutsch wird es
zum beispiel lange dauern
tut übersetzt als sprießen keine feldseite
auf deutsch also in diesem fall wird nehmen
mit braum übersetzt in unseren beiden
fällen würden wir sagen muss letztes foto haben und
dinah warnend kann nicht auf jede hafeninsel zeigen
Park war also in diesen beiden
Fällen Komma, um uns eigentlich
mit man zu übersetzen und
das englische Verb to mean kann
auf drei verschiedene Arten ins
Deutsche übersetzt werden und das ist wirklich verwirrend für
viele deutsche le  arners gibt es
minun heissen und the doulton und ich sehe oft
leute diese wörter verwechseln oft
höre ich sätze wie vas mind us und du
würdest sagen wollen was das bedeutet
aber in diesem fall ist das nicht die
richtige wahl also was ist der unterschied
der  Der erste Unterschied besteht darin, dass sich Doulton und
Tyson wirklich auf eine
Erklärung und die Bedeutung eines Wortes
selbst beziehen. Wenn Ihnen also jemand eine
Geschichte erzählt und es ein Wort gibt, das Sie noch
nie zuvor gehört haben, würden Sie diese Person fragen, ob
sie uns oder den Buslift anspricht  uns, wenn Sie
ihn bitten, dieses bestimmte Wort zu erklären,
aber wenn Ihnen jemand eine
Geschichte erzählt und Sie technisch
jedes einzelne Wort verstehen, aber es nicht wirklich
Sinn macht, würden Sie ihn fragen, ob er zuerst
Schaden anrichten oder meine Schüler sein
möchte, und Sie würden ihn fragen  für seine Absicht oder das
größere Bild im Deutschen ist das Wort
Minor auch mit Minor verbunden,
was Meinung ist, also kannst du es dir so
merken - immer ein bisschen
verbunden mit Absichten einer Person, also
nein  Werfen wir einen Blick auf die folgende
Szene.
Candide war schick, er wird sich selbst stecken.
Die Tochter hat den kleinen Zollziegelfuß bestimmt. Die
Größe macht - Nik Stauskas
-, der hinter den Spanierschuppen getanzt wurde
Dustin tut sein
Wissen Brücke für Tesla gepunktet
noch Niklaus - dies - Ameisen 9 San Juan
Schuppen später zeigen Jetzt, wo wir
den Unterschied zwischen dem
doulton heissen und dem minun erklärt haben, fragen Sie sich vielleicht
immer noch, ob es einen Unterschied
zwischen dem Dalton und dem heissen und ja gibt
Es kann einen Unterschied geben - in der Szene
, die wir beschrieben haben, könnten Sie
Doyen und His austauschen, sie hätten nur die
gleiche Bedeutung, aber wenn Sie
über den Namen einer Person sprechen würden, würden Sie
Highs in jedem Heiser Karina verwenden, Sie können nicht
jedes Bedoya sagen  Karina Ich heiße Karina,
also ist das eine andere Art zu übersetzen
Hyson isin kann zu gemein sein oder
hisin kann erwischt werden. Das nächste Thema ist
das deutsche Wort widerstehen, das
Interesse ist  ing, weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass das
Wort von Deutschlernern ein wenig überbeansprucht wird,
und das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass
es in vielen Büchern im Abschnitt a 1 oder a 2 gelehrt wird,
also hörte ich ein paar
Leute Dinge sagen wie ich habe
Amsterdam busy sticked oder  Jede Position ist
kaum die Sache ist, dass es zwei mögliche
Übersetzungen für das englische Wort zu
besuchen gibt, aber zu besuchen bedeutet auf Deutsch
allgemeiner gizumon, während wenn Sie
über das System sprechen, Sie speziell das
Betrachten von Dingen meinen, es ist wie
Sightseeing, also wenn Sie sagen, es hat  Ein
Bauch hat sich heftig dagegen gewehrt, dass du
nur zum Sightseeing durch die Stadt
gefahren bist, also wenn ich höre, dass ich denke, okay, du
machst eine Liste von Dingen, die du
dir ansehen willst, wie ich Brandenburger
Tor gesehen habe, wenn ich anfange  Ich habe
Checkpoint Charlie gesehen,
das ist wie Widerstand leisten, aber du
redest wahrscheinlich allgemeiner darüber, dass
ich Berlin besucht habe, in Bezug auf Ich
habe die Stadt gesehen, aber ich bin auch in Cafés gegangen, habe Freunde getroffen, bin in Clubs
gegangen oder  zu
bar oder was auch immer du magst, also für mich ist das
Wort besuchen ein bisschen altmodisch
und ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Leute
es überbeanspruchen. Ich persönlich
würde es einem Anfänger nicht beibringen, weil es
vor einer Weile nicht so oft im täglichen gesprochenen Deutsch verwendet
wurde  Ich war zu Besuch bei unserem Freund
Jeremy und er wollte sein Fahrrad nach
draußen bringen, also sagte er, jeder bringt einen Minenvater mit,
aber die Übersetzung von to bring ins
Deutsche ist ein bisschen schwierig und
knifflig, weil es von der
Perspektive abhängt und es unterschiedliche
Übersetzungen geben kann  Sie sprechen über
etwas, das bereits bei Ihnen ist, und
Sie bringen es von einem Punkt zum anderen.
Sie würden es verwenden, wenn Sie auf Deutsch jeweils
eine Achtsamkeit um vier in der Nähe von Sudhir einbringen.
Wenn Sie jedoch über etwas sprechen
, das noch nicht bei Ihnen ist, sondern bei
Ihnen  muss erstmal holen gehen
du redest : H hula achtsam bei
Austin Keller
kommen wir zu den wirklich wichtigen
deutschen Schimpfwörtern, die ein Freund von mir
kürzlich gesagt hat, bringt Isis bei der Arbeit zum Staunen
bald, was auf den ersten Blick sinnvoll erscheint,
funktioniert im Deutschen nicht wirklich,
und der Grund dafür ist, dass wir
zwei Arten von Adjektiven oder zwei Arten von
Positionen haben, an denen Sie Adjektive setzen können,
eines ist das prädikative Adjektiv,
das zum Verb gehört, und eines ist  das
Attribut von Adjektiven, das zu einem
Substantiv gehört, zum Beispiel does house is course ist
ein prädikatives Adjektiv oder das
Cystinose-Haus ist ein Attribut von
Adjektiven und wird daher
mit einem Substantiv
China dekliniert, funktioniert jedoch nur als
prädikatives Adjektiv, sodass Sie sagen können, dass
dies unsere sind  District Resizer kann
man nicht sagen, obwohl die SIS winzige Scheiße in
Ordnung ist, da die Deutschen die Wortwahl wirklich mochten,
also haben wir andere Möglichkeiten
, sie zu kombinieren, weil Reis auch ein
zusammengesetztes Wort ist und Sie es
mit allen Substantiven kombinieren können, die Sie möchten, dass die Gesellschaft
Scheiße Staub vermeidet  ist ein besonders schüchterner
Hocker
die Gesellschaft hat Recht Trish tut dies ist
Island am meisten Spaß an Aufzügen das
Verständnis der korrekten Verwendung deutscher
Präpositionen ist etwas  ing, mit dem jeder Deutschlerner zu
kämpfen hat, und es gibt zwei
Präpositionen, die oft verwechselt werden
, nämlich na und su, und das liegt daran, dass
sie beide im Englischen mit zwei übersetzt wurden,
man kann sagen, ich gehe nach
Thailand, ich gehe in ein Restaurant, ich'
Ich gehe nach Deutschland oder ich gehe ins
Schwimmbad und im Englischen würdest du
die gleiche Präposition verwenden, im Deutschen
wären es andere,
der Unterschied in Deutschland ist, dass du
jetzt immer verwenden würdest, wenn du über
Länder, Städte oder allgemeine Richtungen
wie ich sprichst.  Ich gehe jetzt von hier nach Süden, Juden
oder ich gehe nach links, ist Deana Links,
wann immer Sie über bestimmte Orte sprechen
, würden Sie jedes Jahr sue auf Deutsch verwenden,
einige von uns zu lang, hier ist eine kurze Szene
t zerstören Trick Fun
Reverse Modul up mm, wenn es nicht
Highland Feuer auf Touch-Frauen kann, wir irgendwie,
wie er ein paar Garnelen im Spiel gegessen hat, das
System wird hier beschrieben,
obwohl sie jetzt nicht spaßige
Episoden wie seine Essenz treffen können, wir irgendwie, wie
Vietnamesen  Die indischen Töchter, die gerade
lesen, seit mein Host-Rock-Fan
durchgesickert war, war nur der Gedanke daran
, die nächste Sprühfarbe schneller zu verkaufen, da der typische
Fehler, den Amerikaner auf Deutsch in leichtem
Deutsch machen, 221 wir Zelda aus Wisconsin
als Gastmoderatorin in unserer Show hatten und wann  Sie
traf einen Arzt auf der Straße und
er sagte ihr, dass er in einer
Notaufnahme arbeitete.
Zelda antwortete dies, damit sie gesundheitlich und
genervt sei, aber ja,
verwechselte die Engländer so und der deutsche
Zoo ist ein typischer falscher Freund, und wir
hören das wirklich  Also
verwechseln Sie diese beiden Wörter nicht, weil sie
eine etwas andere Bedeutung haben, aber
es gibt eine einfache Lösung, denn es
gibt ein deutsches Äquivalent zum Englischen,
also einen Zoo, also können Sie in fast allen
Fällen einfach übersetzen
Englisch so zum Deutschen als oh so in
diesem Fall könnte man sagen ich leite auch von
der Athena Erwähnung also hilfst
du jetzt vielen Menschen oder du könntest sagen als
Inder gebürtig oh ho
so treffen wir uns nächste Woche
die l  Das letzte Thema für heute ist der
Unterschied zwischen Spaz Hub und Past
Mountain und Deutsch, und das
höre ich oft, wenn
während unserer US-Tour jemand
verwechselt wurde
Fehler, was ist der Unterschied zwischen
diesen beiden beiden Ausdrücken gibt es in
deutschen Spas Mahon und Spas passieren,
aber nur Menschen wie echte Personen
können Spaß haben jeder Habash war mein Vater
war dort vorbeigekommen Hyzer, aber wenn Sie
über Dinge sprechen, können Sie sagen, dass sie
Spaß machen diese sind  Film markiert Spas McNish
Passe
Dies ist ein Einsiedler-Mischmasch, daher würden sie
oft auch mit dem Dativ verwendet, um
sich auf die Person zu beziehen, die McNeish Pass macht. Schauen Sie
sich nun die folgende Szene an, um zu sehen,
ob Sie den Unterschied zu der
Art meiner Führer erkennen können, die mich feiern  die
aktuelle hier aus gute
moral sukham lucas marker house palace
oh das ist nicht so viel bass auch jeder
haps bus da ich das essen habe und ein
finger laicht ist ein so kyles s  ystole
fertig schnell acaba sollte das video
sein füße sollten sein um wahr zu sein das
war unser video für heute wenn es dir gefallen hat
gib uns einen daumen hoch und vergiss nicht
uns einen kommentar zu hinterlassen wenn du
mehr von dieser art sehen möchtest  von Inhalten in der
Zukunft
jetzt bevor Sie gehen, stellen Sie sicher, dass Sie
ein Förderer von easy German werden und auf
Online-Übungen zu den
in diesem Video vorgestellten Fehlern
zugreifen  tun